uh okay we have a voicemail number
219 to david p you can call it
any time of day here's a caller who
believes i'm a liar
and this is a double whammy david's a
liar and
the show is playing in the background
this is a classic where
they can't even be bothered to pause the
show
so i hear my own voice in the background
as they leave the voicemail this is a
a classic as old as time itself take a
listen
oh my god
what do you mean he didn't do nothing
for the violence
give me a freaking break you're crazy
you're telling you're lying to your
teeth right now
giving me a little bit of credit yeah
you guys just don't know there's nothing
between yours
yeah so that's pretty interesting and i
have to tell you for the howard stern
fans in the audience i know it can't be
because sadly
we we uh we we lost eric the actor
years ago but that is a dead ringer for
for eric the actor a frequent uh former
frequent regular caller
to the howard stern show so very
interesting stuff and again i don't
i've never gotten an explanation as to
why they can't pause the show
to leave their screeds on my voicemail
but you can call if you want to send me
a message
2192 david p
real quick very exciting our good friend
jay tomlinson host of the best of the
left podcast
has just published his 15th anniversary
huge okay you go to best of the left dot
com slash
listen best of the left dot com
slash listen best of the left is
an actual award-winning podcast the
david pakman shows an award-winning
podcast but we've only won awards we
give out
you know so which makes them less
credible jay's best of the left has
actually won awards administered by
someone other than himself
and if you're not familiar with this
show every episode is a deep dive into a
political or cultural topic
you hear clips from a variety of shows
then you also hear
jay's analysis and commentary so 15-year
anniversary for best of the left
great friends of the david pakman show
go to best of the left dot com
slash listen to check it out and the
bonus show doesn't speaking of aw
speaking of award-winning from awards we
give out
the bonus show doesn't stop rudy
giuliani will not represent trump at his
impeachment
trial and i will tell you why and it's
pretty funny parlor
has partially come back to life with the
support of a russian
technology firm i know i know and
uh we will talk about a future trump
presidential library
uh and whether trump would prefer a
theme park rather than a library all of
those stories
and more on today's bonus show
uh get access instantly by becoming a
member
at joinpacman.com coupon code
better21 saves you massive amounts off
of a membership
and lastly join us tomorrow for the
inauguration
11am eastern 8 a.m pacific we will start
with the inauguration of joe biden to
the presidency of the united states
don't miss it youtube twitch and
facebook
i will see everybody then